[Music]
what's the first thing that pops into
your head when i say chip and dale i bet
it's these guys but certainly the second
would be those rascally cartoon
chipmunks chipping down
what if i did something like i am into
good good i love it
[Music]
just want to remind you guys i'll be at
fancon this afternoon hey watch out
i'm keeping myself fit and you know my
updated modern look don't you think
you'd have more fans here if chip did
these events with you i haven't thought
about them in a while i should give them
a call see how life's treating him life
is the worst
which is why you need good insurance
a message on my landline
i don't like that
i know you're still mad about rescue
rangers getting canceled but i just got
a call from the police and i need your
help
i searched the perimeter no clues why
would there be six missing tunes in a
month and not one clue
oh no
chip gail you look different it's no
secret i had the cgi surgery what's been
up with you you know this that other
vague things to fill the space of this
conversation cool
we can see what we can find out and then
pass it along to the officer that that's
all we're gonna do so you're saying the
rescue rangers are back yes
you two come poking around where you
don't belong and i can't have that right
i gotta
what are you looking at honestly your
weird dead eyes
over here go get em
[Music]
i was always more of an alvin and the
chipmunks person you
monster
it was like professional
same time
this is incredible
[Music]
so
[Music]